here you be excited about diving into
this and everything that you're doing
within the project I mean that just gets
me more excited gives me energy and to
discover this and connect with it that's
life-changing and that's everything
that's why I'm still doing it for that
reason to see people connect with that
and get hiked on that it can also go to
another level happiness hey everybody
welcome to a special episode of hot box
and I am Evan Brittany and I might Tyson
like we got a really special really
this dude is the man for many reasons
Pascual welcome man thank you guys
thanks for having me I felt honored to
be here no we're happy to her honored
past was very special in the video as
you will see yes absolutely in this
interview
absolutely man so why don't we hop right
in brother why don't you tell us who you
are and what you do well I'm just a
regular dude that just I appreciate that
especially coming from Allah you know a
legend right so it was a real honor to
be here but it's I produce events mainly
but we do we have a label we do fashion
we do all kinds of different things but
it's all based on a community that is
all about positivity and I'm just the
gatekeeper really with regular
facilitator you know I build these shows
like I I'd want them to be for myself as
an attendee and as a fan of the culture
and started off doing 300 people at my
first event and now we're doing events
with we're doing almost 3 million
tickets a year and some events on just
one weekend we'll do 450,000 people and
it's really just blossomed into this
even larger community that I just has
changed my life and it's been there for
a lot of people that you know to life
can have its challenges people come from
all different backgrounds I get messages
on a daily about these events save their
lives they didn't commit suicide because
of these of the this community it makes
them happy they've met their they have
kids they met their partner at these
events they they're waiting for the next
one to come their way so that they can
connect with people again and it's just
it's the most beautiful thing that I I
felt blessed every day to be able to
work on on these events and be part of
this community and it's been real
positive for for people and there's
there needs to be more of that in the
world so that's why I love it so much
tell us what these events are
specifically for our listeners who don't
know so they're they're not like your
regular concerts because of the
community that's behind it because
there's it's it's it's it's about music
but it's also about connecting with one
another and being your best self
essentially they're also logistically on
the logistic side their pop-up theme
parks we build cities temporary cities
for for the for the weekend and our
Vegas event I mean we have thousands of
people thousands of people working on
the on that show and building that show
to get ready for a hundred and sixty
thousand people to come through the
gates and we have 30,000 people camping
we have theatrics we have amazing
artists on the stages we have art
installations separate than the stages
that also look like art installations we
focus on art in all its forms whether
it's music theatrics installation
sculptures
you mentioned you know Maisie Maisie
balloons Brit you know we try to go off
on try to touch every sense and bring
everyone together and it brings people
into the present moment when you wow
people on that level and that's what our
goal is because that's how it it's
easier to connect people when you have
them in the present moment they're not
thinking about tomorrow whatever it is
yeah so it's it's it's a great community
it's amazing man and this is nocturnal
Wonderland
well nocturnal is one event that I
produce that Mike what are the names of
the all the events you want it's quite a
few how many please tell I mean there's
there's a there's a there's a botch I
also it's some Sumati what are your
biggest the biggest ones EDC or good
would be the biggest and EDC doesn't
just happen in one place we do it all
over the world
BBC's electric panic music electric
daisy carnival car nothing do you see
that's beautiful people dress up there's
I mean everything you can imagine it's a
literal Wonderland no no no more than
that it's more like a spiritual retreat
that's I perceived it yeah that's the
first thing that I've known people that
have gone in that's yeah experience I'm
one day I'm looking at don't even know
why I'm looking down on the wise on I'm
looking at this and then listen I don't
know and I'm saying maybe it's my ego
you know what are you gonna check my ego
sometimes I let my ego and I looked at
all this watching the people and I said
this is how my mind works
this is I'm up as a while this is our
army I don't like to lead this army how
do I get involved in this business you
know I mean I said this is power you
know there's more than just people dance
and I took his power it was like I was
telling it was a political statement
yeah it's powerful every perspective
that you know of and the people from all
the parts of the world as so
disenfranchised from one timely life
they become franchise and they never
want to distance disenfranchised again
and I imagine that you could have the
whole world doing how do you have the
whole world doing that at the same time
how do we do that I have a film have the
whole world at the same time boom do
that what's beautiful is I've been doing
this my whole life since I was a
teenager well starting off on the dance
floor just being part part of this small
community underground for for you to get
that I mean I I try to be a little bit
conservative cuz I think people think
I'm a little you know when I talk about
this no no it's real sad to say without
using a choose optimize for this
egotistical [ __ ] come across
that way you know I mean imagine anybody
doing this at one time at no matter what
time it is over the world you know at
different times of that world one time
and it's filmed all over the world and
it's awesome show and it's all over the
world you can't stop it it's forth in
your faith I just love that
I totally vibe with that I remember
growing up probably in high school in
college for the most part and during my
time in the NFL watching YouTube of
these incredible music festivals the
DJ's this music the energy of the people
and being super inspired by that myself
so I totally it totally resonates with
me and being there's nothing like being
there in person you know it's hard to
describe it's hard to the fact that
you've picked it up by because you
haven't been going in in it deep right
you've watched a lot of video you've you
you feel it naturally you feel it when
you're there it is unbelievable and even
people that say okay I understand it
when they go and they actually feel the
energy of the people and talk to the
people it's it's a whole nother level I
mean it does change you to connect with
a part of yourself that you that that
you don't you can't usually connect with
by just seeing something or being told
something I mean it's really it really
is special and people you know there's
so many people are
searching to be a part of something they
want to feel comfortable in their own
skin they want to be able to dance
without feeling like they're being
judged they want to just let loose and
this is an environment that allows you
to be able to just go off you don't have
to be hard you don't have to be you know
worry about being any anyway right and
it's just in LA especially in the early
90s when I want you know in 1990-91 when
I first discovered it and it was crit
was crazy in LA those years like 80 88
89 91 it was nuts
I mean it was you know I was in what was
nuts like the electric music scene no
I'm saying the city was nuts you know it
was just it was crazy really worked out
hard there was fighting in the streets
there was gangs there was I mean if you
were a young kid growing up in LA and
you weren't protected by if you know you
were in an area where your parents
protected you or you weren't exposed to
but there's a lot of people it was crazy
I mean the gangster rap was huge people
were you get a lot of wannabe gangster
he had real gangsters you had I mean it
was a crazy time in LA this was before
the LA riots nothing that happened in 92
and even into but you could see some
before they right you can see something
bad was gonna happen absolutely yes
Louie had the energy in LA he always had
to watch it back worried about people
shooting and you run into people that
you have conflict with that you never
even met before you know I was jumped to
times you know as a kid hanging out you
know at the parks drinking parties
everyone was trying to you know the
influence do the music and it was just
it was a crazy time to discover this
community in this culture at that time
and not get shot and I walked through
the door I remember the moment and just
feeling I remember someone skipping by
me it was like a big like dude that
could be hard if you wanted but he was
like skipping by me with like a daisy
and his Kengo like it was a trip to see
that because usually people
our sizing you up you know and like what
are you about and kind of reserved and
judging right now seeing what you're
about if not running up on you maybe
even asking where you're from depending
on where you were at that time yeah and
to be in this environment where there
was just this music that was just
unbelievable this is what I think about
when I hit when I might think I'm
thinking about the music playing when I
move and I think about playing my
affirmations about thank you God for my
my hands thank you for my leg
thank you for my I thank you for my
wonderful life and you know that's going
over the people here and it's a petition
repetition thank you for being able to
love being able to read and being able
to understand oh yeah there's too much
love I thought I loved him and I was
just fantasizing being involved what was
that first time you had that experience
Mike watching them in the oven and this
one was watching this one was different
than his boy sitting at my couches
watching it yeah yeah yeah we're
fascinated by it
and that's I wish that happened earlier
than two weeks ago that could happen a
long time and for me that just meant -
back then I was too judgmental I see no
one was your crazy was a white kid [ __ ]
so - it ain't no cut myself Wow holy
[ __ ] they don't even know what this is
and that's where I get that epiphany
phone yeah for me it happened in 1991
well luckily luckily I you know I feel
like so many people so many more
people's lives would have been changed
if they discovered it that early on and
who were the big artists though there
wasn't I mean bigger than just
underground beige it was here in LA I
mean at the scene was so small and at
one point it was non-existent that's why
I started because it existed for a short
period of time
there was a they called it
rave taskforce that when shut down all
the parties are all illegal at the time
so this first experience you had was at
a rave the word rape actually was they
were all called underground to his blog
or even they were calling them raves be
kind of this kind of sort of derogatory
like law-enforcement term is that right
not for me that's who you're talking to
if the if Fox News is covering it's it's
derogatory more likely right if you know
for me it's it's it's the history of the
underground scene you know rave culture
is a beautiful thing were and there's a
great community behind it we're bad
nobody has a bad image that's what I
always had a bad image of it gave you
know the public the press gave it a real
bad image they did you're hung on to the
things that they could find that were
negative and that was what it was what
was it it what would it was all about
versus to success you know me not
getting jumped out of and being a notice
to I knows the love that's gonna [ __ ] my
head up in love yeah who's all on an
uninhibited get let it all go
yeah you know people feel uncomfortable
you being in that you know in that
environment in LA was it was a place
that you felt comfortable in your skin
and [ __ ] good yeah I wish I could
administrate the toll deal where people
are at experiencing that well one day
you can one day you can do that just
keep that keep that in the mind side mic
and just [ __ ] blast it out into the
universe man it's gonna happen
magnificent really letting the music
play devdays let's let it go brother
so that first experience in 91
did that really just inspire you say I
got to do what I can to spread this this
culture this message how did you start
producing these events yourself how does
somebody even do that so in in 91
there was a small scene and I was real
happy being part of it and going and
taking it all in
I got inspired when it died hmm because
I realized how important it was for my
life I just wanted to bring him back and
I wanted somewhere for me and my friends
to have a good time and connect with
others on that level so that's that's
when I got inspired and it crashed and
burn and it was when was that that was
in 92 really that it really it died
between the LA or a lot of these parties
used to happen in south central and
downtown LA and between the riots and
the curfews that were going on for like
a month or so there you had to be in by
certain how these events would go all
night and the parties prior to the LA
riots getting shut down because they
were illegal in there being this task
force out there because they were
usually in like an abandoned warehouse
or building somewhere right yeah they
were in fields where you'll is dry
lakebeds mmm wherever wherever there was
space to fit a few thousand people
wherever you can pull it off yeah yeah
yeah so that's when I got inspired was
when when it died and I was I had a void
in my life being able to go to these
events I mean it was I really I mean I
lived for it my room had all the Flyers
on the walls
I had a sermon Vega base bins in my
bedroom when did you think I could make
a livin uh for this that's a good
question I actually never thought about
that two decades later dwell I was just
about the goals of having a consist and
I knew that it made me happy and I knew
it made others happy and I just wanted
to be alive and and and and be available
to to myself and the people that I loved
which I loved people
so I you know I wanted to spread the
word so I just and I wanted it to exist
and that's that's what wasn't happening
for a while so yeah so that's that's
really really how I started and started
really Swamy 300 people and was your
first event my first event had 300
people how did you go about it what did
you you found the space you printed
fliers what was your workflow yeah I was
at Kinkos cutting up fly you know fliers
sticking them I was doing the flyer runs
and making copies and I was out there
promoting I was on Venice Beach trying
to find people that that remembered the
old days which was only a year prior but
it felt like it's an attorney because it
had died a year prior and I was talking
people what it was about and had 300
people show up on the corner of Crenshaw
and Slauson was my first dangerous man
dangerous family said that maybe
connected with one another right looking
at him what do you said you know it's
beautiful it's a yoga studio another
warehouse that I used Wow I went Mehta
the woman that runs a spot and we were
doing a little documentary on the
history and talked to the woman and then
incredible what determination will we'll
go through and do yeah I mean even you
know don't care and with death yeah yes
I thought yeah I remember all the a lot
of the people used to cruise Crenshaw
right there and there's these little
turnoff spots and I'd be setting up the
sound system and there was just like a
row of impalas just you know with
hitting that the hydraulics and and we
were getting ready for the rave party it
was going on there that night it was
just it was two different cultures
coming you know it was it was great well
I worked out perfect that parties would
go off I used that spot a couple times
so I got busted but mmm and then we
started moving around around the city
although wherever we could find to do
these events did you have a deejay
somebody to get the to put on the music
like who was it did you do it
yes so I hired DJ's local LA underground
deejays that when playing the parties
when the party when the events were
still happening and there was still some
record vinyl shops on Melrose and I
would go in there and I would talk to
the DJ's the DJ's used to be able used
to work at the record store played the
party so you could hear a track that was
played at an event and then go into a
record store and talk to the people what
was that song yeah like this and yeah
you try to mimic good old business yeah
so was it was a real small scene and and
the dream was to grow it on a level that
it's it's grown to and I loved it that's
so I think that's so key that you
weren't even thinking about making money
you were just thinking about how do I
spread this love and happiness to as
many people as I can if I did if there
was spreadsheets in front of me and I
did it the goal was to make money I
would have I could I wouldn't have moved
forward yeah because it was there was no
money in it I was broke for many many
years Top Ramen apartment with rent
control luckily just barely you know it
getting being able to pull it off but I
mean when you don't even see it I mean I
was the happiest I was as happy as I I
am now then that none of that matters
madam 200,000 people behind you talking
about we want rent control but I said I
say that it's not like I'm not saying I
wasn't struggling because I was happy
right and it was the best the MA was
exciting I was in love with everything
what you're doing that's so important is
easy yeah important for in life you know
I think that's like you were saying it's
that's the beauty of these of the
festivals in these carnivals is that you
know people in today's age get so bogged
down with the mundane details of
surviving
having a job that pays you money so that
you can eat and live hey it bills after
you pay your bills
you know and trying to figure out how
they're gonna be successful or who they
are in the world and being in an
environment with with music and the
sensations that you provide and create
you know it reminds people of what
really matters and who they are and you
know it taps them back into the spirit
of themselves you know which we're so
just we're so distracted from than this
time yeah
and I think that's amazing I mean I'm
I'm so hyped you give me energy
because so someone like yourself so
successful a legend and I mean boxing
you don't think of many names in boxing
what's oh yeah oh yeah we're connected
what do you got chum gate and jet so to
you have you know it's actually given to
me from this was given to me you'll
you'll go to these events and you'll
receive gifts it's a it's amazing of
course they will remove her but uh you
know for you to cause so I your energy
it gets me more excited about to work
harder and do more for people that find
see the positivity in this and it can
change our lives and it you know it
makes them here you be excited about
diving into this and everything that
you're doing with the project I mean
that just gets me more excited gives me
energy
because there's people that are again
there they're angry they're there
they're depressed they're so many
different things going on and to
discover this and connect with it that's
life-changing and that's everything
that's why still today there's you know
the business is successful but I'm still
doing it for that reason to see people
connect with that and get hyped on that
way it can also go to another level
happiness absolutely yeah I can go to
another level of it yeah so let's talk
about what we're doing together
what are you and Mike partnering on here
ain't it please to [ __ ] bring to the
world man how are we gonna have a
worldwide [ __ ] Electronic Music
Festival so as I mentioned before we
build cities for the weekend some some
shows there's a show that we do that
costs fifty sixty million dollars to
build for the weekend and then what do
we do we tear it down after building it
and people express three days so one of
the dreams has been rather than just
building a city and then tearing it down
a permanent destination where you can
host amazing events and just me and Mike
have known each other very long we just
recently met and it was through he's
already done if he's done a festival
kind festival yeah he's building an
oasis in the middle of desert the lazy
river different levels of accomodations
your ass fields wave pools I mean he
goes and chef's tender can't glamping
strip beautiful and then there's me I
just told you my studio right yeah so
that the perfect synergy exactly yes
instantly we are we started you know
dreaming up ideas and and connecting and
talking and and it's just it's it's
we're exploring a lot of different
things and less amount of things and
just really excited about what he's
working on and it ties in to what I do
for what I've devoted my life to yeah so
that's a little a little bit what I'd
like to find some property to do the
show to the misérable so it's that's one
of the hardest things I have spent many
oh yeah I mean decades trying to find
venues to be able to produce these
events and it's it's either the roads
can't handle it this the
government is thinks we're bringing
Woodstock
they don't have a great image of mass
gatherings uh-huh - they're little
afraid of it things have changed in
recent years and we've crossed over the
music has really gotten more popular so
people now it's it's great I'll be
talking to someone at an offer an
officer or a fire marshal and they'll
say ice you know I go to these parties
or I used to go these parties or hey can
I meet this artists like that things
have changes matured but it's still
difficult on a logistic side to find a
place that can house host this many
people how many people usually I mean
we're doing events and we do hundreds of
events throughout the year and we have
you know a biggest event that you do 450
460 thousand people at one time 160,000
a day oh wow
so still whoa so there are smaller
festivals - 50,000 60,000 people in in
in Mexico City we do 120 in Las Vegas we
do 160 in Orlando we do 90,000 a day and
you know on Halloween we do 60th out of
different events and you asked earlier
about the brands we didn't get past EDC
but we have a nocturnal we have EDC we
have escaped we have a lot of different
events all different sizes we've talked
about Mike's property has you know four
or five hundred four hundred twenty
acres yes put around 700 more oh yeah
yeah we get a lot of room who wants more
yeah right next door so that can
accommodate a hundred thousand plus
people well amazing what I do Jack's my
cue last weekend in the guardian bunny
deuce that sounds like your problem man
I don't care go rob a bank okay put some
money down and win like a man the matter
with you don't even listen to that
[ __ ] man going on right now
my bookie online
[ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] him I'm gonna use my
cookie online because I think that
[ __ ] from them no that's right my
bookie online you play you win they pay
that's what I'm talking about done all
day every day let's do it my bookie
online boom my bookies got the fastest
payouts and better lines than any other
sports book join now and my bookie will
double your first deposit just use promo
code hotbox and to activate the offer
that's promo code hotboxing and my
bookie will double your first deposit
visit my bookie AG today so are you
thinking to bring one of your current
festivals there or are you thinking of
creating a brand new one specifically
Parker I might I'm thinking the office
yeah works fine where explain everything
anything yeah that's awesome
well here is here's a little shot of the
property this is the T ranch this map
here is 490 acres on either side of the
tent out in Desert Hot Springs in Palm
Springs we had the kind of music
festival out there beautiful the
mountains are right behind it and it'd
be a backdrop yeah it's gonna be
incredible to have to build one of your
cities out there dude
that's my man in Antigua I think surely
that's equal that's another property
there's another props are connected to
that we're exploring something different
at what would that be well where the
there's been a lot of different ideas
but don't want to don't want to don't
want to rock the boat
yeah don't want to say what yeah we have
to all right so that's fair that's fair
let's see beautiful property it doesn't
matter what it's called if you're right
they're right I mean there's a sound
system in it and you're able to be out
there with amazing people and yeah
the turquoise water there that's well
the best trips I ever took was in
Anguilla let's see what else we got
I mean look at the properties dude you
just build I mean that's what we met
would be good that's what we're gonna do
yeah that's gorgeous let's see okay
here's our glamping yeah glamping out at
the ranch that's the inspiration photos
for or actually those are 3d rendering
mic huh you guys did those renders yeah
yeah so I guess on the left is some
inspiration photos and then some renders
of what they actually want to build yeah
and if this these kind of accommodations
were at we're out of festival I mean it
would be an amazing experience and
that's what we're all about is creating
the best experiences you can you had
this you know you have security guard at
the from the lake and to your private
yeah space beautiful
Robin Jimmy we have a festival called
electric forest that is in the woods of
Michigan you know we have cabins like
that and actually the community is so
amazing people there is no security like
that people just respect to want to know
they don't even go into each other's
spaces you have these campout festivals
where some people are glamping some
people are just straight-up camping
let's though and you do that at a lot of
your events ahead full I want to do more
camping I love camping because when you
have and I just added camping to our
largest festival EDC in Vegas I was just
about to ask you about because on your
nocturnal Wonderland it says art camping
and music this is my first festival that
I ever produced as a teenager and I'm
still doing it today it's the
longest-running festival that I'm that
I'm aware of well in Dan in the dance
music world in America so it's been it's
been quite a ride with this one it's
it's amazing but yeah this is gonna
happen at a venue called Glen Helen
there's camping it's a black light
themed festival that Crilley really
comes alive when the Sun sets and sky
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's right you gotta
make more like a Mardi Gras no that [ __ ]
though yeah that big float this [ __ ]
people on the floats art cars making
McCarthy attrex art installations but
really you know what makes it these
events that's beautiful where's Glen
Helen Glen Helen is in San Bernardino
California and there's a lot of grass
grass at this it's a park essentially
and there's a water slide park attached
to it that we know isn't up somebody's
that's that's a lot of fun how about
they give me [ __ ] about this in New York
in New York and York can be difficult
you know we've done vessels we've done
EDC and we did 50 thousand a hundred
thousand people over two days for EDC in
New York I ended up doing Orlando
because there was grass there I'd the
venue's are tough to find only in New
York we were producing it in a parking
lot of a stadium and that's why I
decided to not continue there because I
wanted to find a better spot and I'm
still on the search it's a little tough
doing what Prospect Park I mean that
would be that would be real you know it
would be amazing
yeah but you got to get them get good
for the pro quo yeah it is I cam in New
York what that what that what I call the
people at the the people behind there
what's the people work sandrak know the
people that are behind all the napkins
and all that [ __ ] the union people you
know what you know you're [ __ ] because
in New York still gangster because
unions you know you're they one night
they don't talk nice either
they don't let you and they they work at
their own pace yeah per hour and they do
not let you touch anything if you want
to move the napkin to the left on food
they want they don't want me touching a
thing they need to do it and they're
gonna do it when they're ready so we try
to get out there and look for things
let's do your buddy they do the buddy
system down there yeah so it was a very
that was another reason I'm glad you
mentioned that because not only did we
all use a parking lot and try to
transform it into a magical magical
venue for the weekend which took a lot
when you're putting that much into
something and then you're dealing with
the union you know it gets really pricey
oh so costly that even at sellout you're
it's tough to make sense so this is this
is the lineup Alan Walker sex machine
experience we've got Black Tigers sex
machine bleep blue camel fat campaign
trip b2b Zeke beats back to back that
they're gonna go back to back on the
table and the turntables whoo Chris
Lorenzo deadbeats DJ snake camel white
night gentlemen's club golden features
insomniac records so insomniac that's
another one of your events so insomniac
is the company that's the company says
all the events okay cool
and we have a are insomniac records is
our label we I'm excited to say we just
had our first Grammy nomination with a
Fisher's track that we've been that was
exciting for us but yeah we're in Sonic
is the company that produces the events
it's our Joshua and it's it's a name of
the that's what the name of the events
were when I first started mmm so when I
did the crunch on Slauson party I was
called insomniac Fridays and I every
weekend on a Friday I would do a
different warehouse how long were you
doing that I did that for a year for a
year every Friday there was a different
party that you had to find out where it
was and then I had my one year
anniversary and I decided and that's
when I did a nocturnal which was my
first festival so it's insomnia presents
nocturnal Wonderland
amazing man why do they have to work
that wouldn't have their own property
yeah I know where the people I know
we're gonna be every year every day
every time of the year that's where
they're gonna be they didn't have to
think we would be left to a far out
that's too expensive they know make a
plan they can't dissipate it and they
have no problem being there it makes
sense to me buddy you don't have to [ __ ]
with the unions you know well especially
if the infrastructure is built right you
know we want to change the event up the
different events up so it's a different
experience for people that come but the
infrastructure you can have ready to go
so you're rebuilding it every time so
it's it's it's great you know very very
exciting thing to explore and Amanda
much money you [ __ ] we have panned it
down all the time yeah yeah you can
focus on the fun stuff ya know the nuts
and bolts of it aren't aren't as fun as
the changing up the the concept of the
event making sure that the experience is
good yeah and having the the foundation
on the level that that Mike's talking
about building is is that's it's
exciting for the whole culture and for
the scene
it's so awesome man well man you mean
the crowd gave it did Prague in Prague
you did Prague it I haven't done product
it Russia you haven't done a Russia but
we talked about that at - oh [ __ ]
I wonder what Israel will be like that's
true
Israel's goes on Phil it was great yeah
we're looking around in Israel you do
someone that we yeah it's dope dude
we're all over the world it's a it's
beautiful you know we we have grown so
much in the past two years and we're
just getting started we just had a 25
year anniversary and I feel like it's
year one for us wow that's exciting and
in China China China how about the the
riots that are going on there man people
are waking up in China right yeah Hong
Kong well um it's pretty interesting
what do you mean by waking up they you
talking about of some kind of revolt so
to speak yeah yeah I think that you know
living on
that type of communism communist regime
where their censorship there's all sorts
of it only congratulation suits them you
know could the way they handle money now
in China and felt things on the streets
not in this is now in China that is very
not common capitalist super capitalist
yeah yeah you know yeah person alone but
the government works like this you can
have a you grab you could become a multi
billionaire right but it's just certain
or money you could leave the country
would not very interesting interesting
so you could be a billionaire did you're
probably going into three hundred
thousand dollars out of you going to
Vegas or something probably let's you
know why you gotta take that much money
to probably you have to explain that as
well I'm not sure but most likely that's
what it was like cuz I know I was in
Finland when it was a communist country
and people have visited Finland from
Russia
mmm it was like twenty people in online
grown adults and one guy had a gun he
was like guarding and watching them yeah
wow this is crazy and the other guy the
other guy that that mile beach no
cowering check those guys they went
where on the didn't go to of Singapore
but they went somebody else and they
study went to the dope business opium
yeah once the capitalists that lost to
the Communists and China they went to
opium business well you know the oldest
cannabis plants they found or discovered
or ten thousand years old from China
really the Emperor would use it Wow yeah
yeah that's cool yeah the who are we you
know you know we should talk but what I
think sometimes always people that we
have to be higher all of our life but
we're always have we don't have our
joint or we don't have a one of the
cocaine our liquor license I'm not happy
no my life is miserable why is that why
we built like that human beings why we
built it there's no it's over the life
is over once we don't have just no more
well there's not enough party
out there pushing this is out there
Pasquale me hey that was seriously -
yeah no really I mean hey sweet makes
people happy for real I get direct
messages about it every day on a level
of like I'm not gonna kill myself
because I'm waiting for the next one
it's awesome yeah even be thinking about
yourself all day that's what we do most
times just think about ourselves or
think of surrounding ourselves right how
do people live it the hell you get the
[ __ ] [ __ ] - shut up you know be in
the moment
yep it's you you zap them into being
into the moment when they walk through
those gates for us that's what on our
side there's other ways to do that but
that's what we you know we've devoted
our lives to doing and it's been very
gratifying
I thought you shut the ego damn I'm
making someone else happy yeah you know
I make somebody happy shut it down stop
thinking about yourself talking about
yourself all the day yeah I mean we
could go really deep on the why we want
to get high but yeah because that's what
we're always seeking them or seeking
connection with something greater than
ourselves something higher something
we're seeking connection with God and
these chemicals that we put into our
bodies help us achieve that even if it's
only for a moment you know you know what
you know you can have you can have those
moments whether it's you know some
smoking or can just be in one of these
events taking in the energy absolutely
but you you can learn from those moments
and take it into your everyday life and
that's what I see happening a lot yeah I
live I talk a lot about about it keep
going back to what we do in these events
because this is what I live every day
and what I'm you know only pretty much
only thinking about it from family I'm
thinking about these events and this
community and that's what I love seeing
it changing people I mean really
changing people's lives where they come
they get this feeling they connect and
they leave a different person and they
they're they're nicer through themselves
to themselves others just on on a daily
and that's a transformation that that
keeps me going
and I I felt that's what you're hyped
you know you love that too you know okay
how do you share 53 or your vibrational
shift for what the [ __ ] am i doing
listen to this you look okay this is a
new music why this is really what
funding it's beautiful beautiful yeah
it's awesome man you feel so much in it
you know thank you wait till you go to
your first CD see ya gonna be so hard to
be awesome right [ __ ] you cry all the
time let the tears flow baby it's all
good why did you do you everything with
the why did that for me why do I get the
light I mean I pinch myself every day
and I'm grateful for it
I asked myself you know what I I I'm not
that I'm asking myself
I think I'm thankful every day and I
pinch myself every day you know the
beautiful people that are around me the
beautiful things that I get to work on
the Mesa that come to these events to be
able be part of it is something that
makes me happy and and makes me want to
work harder this is your purpose man I
don't know I love it this is your
purpose it's all vibrations you know
yeah music is a direct representative of
that but you know when you go to a
festival like one of yours your
vibration gets raised to a certain level
and then you leave there and your
vibration is still high so when you're
around the people that you've been
around your relationship with them is
shifted because their vibration hasn't
changed and yours has and as you go
through life and your vibration continue
to raise you sift out all the people
until you get to the top you know
wherever that is repetitious yeah okay
very few people get down the information
of thought you know it doesn't seem that
that seemed like in the very in a lot of
successful people but the Senators
people very few people have thought and
it's just hard to believe that that's
true
very few people do multi over to the
repetition yeah your starter work
everyday do this every everything same
thing over to go to you know I know I'm
gonna come here every day but I don't
know if I'm I wake up every day you know
yeah and very few people get I'd hate
whatever come from while I work on that
to an Internet the next thing you know
there is person yeah
life we are who we think we are yeah
that's right
even we don't want to face ourselves we
all who we think we are yeah and even if
you if you don't want to face yourself
you're gonna continue to be take
yourself into that persona know that
about it we're reborn reborn Los Angeles
you were I'm born a raisin now Wow what
do you skateboard analysts deep water
breakdancer yeah I I surfed I
skateboarded I broke broke danced on the
boardwalk I was have you know graffiti
artists I was in graffiti crews I wasn't
as good as some of my friends it but
that but I was in graffiti crews and
yeah I grew up grew up here in LA
awesome and then got into going to
underground parties yeah and a little
bit of DJing in the early early days
when I first start but I decided to go
the route of producing the events
because there would have been no parties
what was it that brought you to that
first that very first one you went to my
just my friends your friends invited you
yeah DJ am hmm am did you an Wow
and it dude named Seth he's in a band
called crazy on those kids I grew up
where easyto yeah I love crazy and come
bolita come come my lady
so yeah he brought me to my first
underground party and
the early 90s Wow I was just mind blown
actually we are all hanging out and
little Wes what if time was very
different we would hang out there and it
was a like but I mean it was all every
kids from everywhere would just
congregate there on a Harley basis
no no well college kids were there too
but it was more like a lot of taggers
and tag bangers and some gangsters and
some and what killed it all actually it
was a shooting and a murder they're from
they had the movie either boys in the
hood or colors mmm one weekend in the
whole city like I think a college
student got got got hurt in the
crossfire of things and kind of killed
Westwood from being this hangout but it
used to be you choose a spot where all
the trouble kids would you know all that
other would come and hang out yeah
there's an arcade the zoo is kind of a
dope area there was a lot of yeah yeah a
lot of fun [ __ ] going on there was a lot
of fights that's where I had gotten
jumped a couple times no one Park West -
yeah Wow no it's crazy
let's food is hard back in the day I
mean you had kids from yeah I mean
they're good so no it wasn't it wasn't
it was a collection point yeah yeah yeah
but it was there was a lot of stuff
going there people would come from
everywhere to hang out in Westwood meet
girls play arcade get in trouble
whatever it was and then there was that
big shooting there and it kind of killed
it for the opening of one of those two
movies I forget where I was crazy
um so that was in a mine that killed
with John Anton Barry he got killed dear
well that's what his call was coming
from I was just shooting they shot his
car oh yeah that might have been the
same same situation but yeah was it was
risk Wessel was pretty crazy no no shoot
ma'am
I never free yeah I'll never forget this
crew called NBT holy [ __ ]
it was you know it was with that stand
for nothing but trouble [ __ ] [ __ ] that
and we we were from those guys and we
were yeah they came and started jumping
it's from over there DT and that was
that was just one there was a lot of
stuff that was was going on yeah there
that was crazy it was a very tumultuous
time absolutely
but then what those guys I was at Seth's
house and I remember we were wearing
Dickies and converse and if you were
like some some of the guys were wearing
Nike cortezes and white t-shirts in
starter jackets Raiders or Kings
baseball you know one day I don't know
when this happened I was at those guys
house and they were putting on giant
overalls
they were pinning daisies to their
overalls and they were wearing top hats
with fur on it I was like I was thrown
wearing my Dickies sagging my pants
what is what are you guys doing right
now where are you taking me right now
so that was going to an underground
underground party we went to a Matt
point and then we went to a warehouse
and I was like this and everyone was
super cool the reason to dress up for
was that what's the reason that they
dress up like that for well it was it
was it was part of that just like it's
just like rock and roll and and hip-hop
have certain swagger and style about
them
dance music rave music rave culture at
that time baggy overalls Doc Martens or
shell toe Adidas with even fat laces the
inspiration from hip hop culture there
was that in the rave culture as well so
and you know walking in and feeling that
energy no wonder they could wear you
know daisies pinned to their overalls
and furry hat like it's all good here
yeah well good for you want just be you
and yeah people were and then we brought
you know we used to dance in the circles
there I used to love the music and the
music reminded me of the early what you
heard on the Venice Boardwalk that was
booming out of the giant ghetto blasters
that that people were holding on the boy
ladies were doing this [ __ ] yeah
music having a big [ __ ] radio [ __ ]
yeah it was a craft craft work and even
like nucleus that jammed up
I mean def Punk well that's uh it's the
same same women that was like bright you
know bradford earlier yeah yeah
sounded like I mean it was Dan it was
danger music and it was walking into
that first underground party and hearing
that music and feeling that vibe and
then there was dance circles at the
parties and people were breakdancing to
house and techno and uh prime doing you
know house dancing and stuff it was it
was everything that I want I needed and
wanted it was better than getting going
at the to the park and people starting
getting drunk and like be like hey let's
start a new crew who lets you know and
then people jumping each other in the
little cruise and then like real
gangsters coming and like sweating us
like it was you you know is better than
that
it was I I as a kid I felt like going to
Venice Beach going my first underground
party mmm because Venice Beach you had
people of all kinds coming together
you had the street performers you had
the artists you had all the tourists
that were there you had the the
gangsters that were there you had the
break dancers you had the surfer as the
skaters it was all kinds of people
coming together in Venice Boardwalk
majority of time there was some times
where there was like some riots on the
on the boardwalk but majority of time it
was all love down there it was a lot of
artists and unique people coming
together there yet homeless people you
had weirdos freaks everything going on
underground party and going to rave it
was like the same it was the same thing
so I felt very instantly very
comfortable there and the positive vibes
chippers it was just a positive I am a
network television NBC ABC anything like
that I have yeah yeah rave book the
music yeah yeah I've gone to on some on
press runs and beyond I've been on
CNBC and Fox and News I've been on a lot
of niat they can a lot of news channels
and I flew to New York to go to be on
CNB C n CNBC yeah I don't watch the news
really too much but nothing good now
you've been on hotbox and brother I mean
and this is amazing that's sitting there
sitting with you a deuce thank you so
much man that's really excited for the
future campaign saying thank you my
Creed episode a lot of great things
coming god is great future is bright
alright everybody thanks for checking us
out another great episode of hotbox and
I'm Evan Britton I'm Mike Tyson Pasquale
Rotella do you want anybody to know
anything about you want to say anything
to the world damn if you haven't been to
a insomniac event or even any any Dance
Music Festival and you think you know
what it is you got to check it out it's
probably nothing like that it's amazing
it's good for the soul come check us out
insomniac calm you can check out a lot
of events there and yeah awesome
appreciate it also shaping thank you
very much peace everybody all right I
didn't even smoke any weight
[Music]